de l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Madame Catherine Desroches et
Madame la Ministre de la réforme de
l'État de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique
c'est monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre en cas d'accident de travail ou
de maladie professionnelle dans
certaines circonstances des agents
territoriaux sans être inapte à toute
fonction ne peuvent être reclacées au
sein de leur propre collectivités ils
sont alors soit indéfiniment maintenu en
arrêt de maladie soit admis à la
retraite après la procédure mise en
oeuvre par la collectivité or les agents
placés dans cette situation ne peuvent
pas bénéficier d'actions de formation
réservée aux seules personnes en
situation de travail puisque le cadre
statutaire actuel les en empêche dès
lors ne t'ont ne peut-on pas créer une
position statutaire nouvelle type congé
de reconversion afin de permettre aux
agents maintenus en congé de longue
maladie d'être placé en position
d'activité de reconversion et leur
donner ainsi un accès des démarches de
formation qualifiantes et
professionnalisante susceptibles de
favoriser
leur reclassement je souhaite donc
Madame la Ministre avoir votre avis sur
cette proposition et le cas échéant dans
quel délai pourrait-elle être mise en
oeuvre je vous remercie mes chers
collègues les paroles étaient madame
Marylise le branchu ministre de la
réforme de l'État de la décentralisation
et de la fonction publique
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice c'est vrai que votre question
est extrêmement intéressante parce que
les modalités de reclassement des
fonctionnaires qui sont devenus inaptes
à exercer les fonctions du fait d'une
invalidité sont insuffisamment
aujourd'hui adaptés pour permettre aux
employeurs publics comme au
fonctionnaires d'ailleurs de dérouler
une seconde carrière on a un vrai souci
et les procédures actuelles mettent en
jeu des instances au fonctionnement qui
lourd
des cadres statutaires qui n'offrent que
peu d'alternatives aux employeurs
publics et je trouve que votre souci est
fortement justifié puisque tout cela
conduit souvent à une désinsertion
professionnelle des fonctionnaires qui
ont eu un accident de la vie quel que
soit la nature et le reclassement des
fonctionnaires territoriaux vous l'avez
rappelé il est recréé les régies pardon
par les articles 81 et suivant la loi du
26 janvier 84 relativait la fonction
publique territoriale et par un décret
de septembre 85 mais un fonctionnaire
territorial peut en droit à l'issue d'un
congé de maladie n'être plus
physiquement apte et ce sera constaté à
exercer ses fonctions le comité médical
est souverain en la matière l'autorité
territoriale a donc une obligation de
moyens pour classer cet agence et un
arrêté du Conseil d'État du 2 octobre
2002 qui condamne la Chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de Meurthe-et-Moselle
mais le fonctionnaire peut se voir
proposer par l'autorité territoriale si
c'est possible un changement d'emploi ou
même s'il n'est plus à exercer
l'ensemble des employations graves un
changement de cadre d'emploi dans le
cadre de cette reconversion une
formation peut s'avérer nécessaire les
textes ne prévoit pas de formation
spécifique liée à une reconversion pour
raison de santé par exemple il est par
conséquent nécessaire dans un contexte
allongement des carrières du fait
notamment du recul de l'âge de départ à
la retraite d'ouvrir une vraie réflexion
sur la prévention bien sûr et la prise
en charge de l'invalidité dans la
fonction publique c'est la raison pour
laquelle je souhaite dans le cadre de la
négociation pour l'amélioration des
conditions de vie au travail que j'ai
ouvert avec des organisations syndicales
représentatives de la fonction publique
aborder l'ensemble du champ c'est-à-dire
la prévention des risques professionnels
fera l'objet de plusieurs groupes de
travail avec en particulier la
prévention des risques psychosociaux
qu'on a sous-estimé dans la fonction
publique mais aussi des risques liés à
la pénibilité physique ainsi que tous
les troubles qu'on connaît tous bien
maintenant malheureusement musculeuse
collectif l'amélioration du
fonctionnement des instances médicales
participant aux procédure de
reclassement fera aussi l'objet de
discussion je crois qu'elles seront
longues mais elles sont absolument
nécessaires et enfin sur la base des
rapports de Ligue 1 j'ai examinerai avec
les organisations syndicales les
conditions dans lesquelles nous
reconversion professionnelle peut être
mise en place j'ai fait
organiser cette négociation avec des
groupes importants
sur les parcours professionnels la
formation professionnelle le changement
d'affectation le passage d'une
administration à une eau d'une
collectivité locale à l'état de l'État
aux collectivité locale ou à la fonction
publique hospitalière nous n'avons pas
les bonnes pratiques aujourd'hui et
madame je m'engage avec les
organisations syndicales à trouver
réponse à votre question merci Madame
ministre paroles et Madame Catherine des
roches si elles le souhaitent
merci madame la ministre en effet des
réels problèmes existent et je vous
remercie de l'échéancier que vous avez
donné même s'il y a pas de date précise
mais la réflexion est donc est donc
lancée en effet pour avoir organisé une
table ronde avec le Centre de Gestion et
l'Association des Maires dans mon
département
des collectivités on s'est aperçu en
effet notamment pour les petites
collectivités qui avait de réelles de
réels soucis tant financier mais surtout
de postes qui n'existe pas dans la
collectivité et puis de blocage
statutaire il y avait également des
problèmes par rapport aux avis des
commissions de réforme et en effet je
pense que le chantier que vous lancez
est très attendu par les par les maires
et par les présidentes communautés de
communes notamment